I'm going to the bathroom okay excuse me  excuse me give me give me excuse me  [Music]  Andre Andre where are you you looking  for my boyfriend  girl I'm doing it right now dude Meegan  bigger dose me I'm searching you Andre  me I'm Dre me I'm your hating come here  I'm Dre I'm Jay Andre Andre I'm Jay Siri  call Andre  I'm Jay where I yell a bunch will you  FaceTime me I'm not gonna do it right  now you wouldn't be able to see me it's  [ __ ] talking to you  I know if I can't find you okay I'm  gonna turn around I'm right there [ __ ]  [ __ ] [ __ ]  stop yelling at me thinkin if you  sustained a head injury or had a stroke  in the last ten minutes  what do you mean makin dude put your  phone yep Oh wake up oMG did you just  hang up yes not talking you sir I'm  talking my boyfriend it's me can you  show me audience I want to see my boy  stop me you need  evening  evening and easy  I can't find the bathroom  you